all right Hoss boy good old bum bum and
toss my weight who do I want to be oh my
god these look like creepypastas I know
they said this is a lizard person for
sure that's my middle name I think that
guy's kind of handsome I I don't know
what you got going on but you know well
you're a [ __ ] lizard person right
fine thank you excuse me
I can call me a lizard person you can't
call me a lizard person all right
guide me through it sensei all right I
will okay so you you've played the old
version right yeah a little bit I think
I did two episodes on it yeah the brunt
of it is the same the Sasquatch is in
the forest and so you have to do you
ever go axle are you I did but I got rid
of it so now all I can do with like in
the forest you make your body quality
turn to [ __ ] that's your superpower yes
super gain I have a preamp and just to
have scarlet ah you don't like to go XLR
I did but it has like a weird limiter on
it that was [ __ ] up my audio yeah all
right fine then Oh judge me yeah
whatever man
hey some of us don't like being top at
the top of the line I get it no it's
fine I I'm not here about quality
you just have to yell at things and push
a lot of videos that's the jacksepticeye
I know did we crash to get here no no no
no no no no I was driving this sign is
broken no come on man don't don't pin
this on me that wasn't that bad
should I pick up this meat yeah I
already picked up some meat pick up some
traps
Bigfoot's vegetarian he's not that it's
the thing the funny thing is he's
absolutely the opposite of that he's a
mega carnival he loves meat he shoves
meat into him at every opportunity that
guy or gal Bigfoot could be a lady
that's true it's not called big man
no girl big footers could have big big
face can be a woman too or anybody in
between God face can you imagine if
there was a monster hall
big face that's a creepypasta right
that's huge like 20-foot face looming
from behind a tree very small legs
we shouldn't mod this game put big face
in no horrible big feet big face nothing
else between him so like before the
flare gun scares him away your gun will
hurt him but not that much wait how do
we kill him then yeah well you gotta
shoot him a lot we gotta go get more
bullets we got to go get more traps we
got to get more supplies because we do
not have enough to kill them right off
the bat which is the weird thing okay I
feel like we're very underprepared for
this adventure yeah yeah welcome to
Bigfoot okay follow me I'm so glad that
we waited until it was Derek to do this
oh yeah whoa boo-ki that's a deer I
think we don't need to get its meat
right now but you could shoot it if you
want hmm
I feel like Bambi's okay for now dead
yeah well stop talking about things
faces man you gotta learn to ignore the
face where's big ass the mythical big
ass is a big booty [ __ ] I found big
asses ass prints coming this way they
look like giant deer who's it's like one
of those Spaceballs you sit on the
little rubber ones bounce around but
it's just your ass it's like it's like
the episode of South Park when he shoved
his balls in the micro just gonna get a
little cancer Sharon no cancer can I
bring this yeah apparently I didn't even
know that worked the music kids listen
to these days I found little face yeah
oh yeah well you know not much of a face
left anymore
little skull that's my rap name little
skull little skull yeah well you want to
sling me a rap little skull my name is
little skull and I'm really sad maybe
because I don't have a dad he went out
to get a pack of cigarettes so it left
me really depressed Oh
Jesus Christ little skull man he's got
bears upon bears okay yeah bars bars
emotional bars trapping him inside you
got to let go little skull man I'm
harboring a lot of guilt why did you do
something to your dad I'm gonna get sent
to prison and then I'm gonna snitch on
everybody oh okay all right
sweet topical reference of today's show
and climate thank you
you want to talk about politics next
yeah absolutely um there's only a
first-aid kit up here but you grab that
one I think I'm full up okay so what I'm
gonna do now is I'm actually going to go
off whoa Fox uh got him no I hit a tree
doing some ways in your bullets we need
them for big things you know you're kind
of wrecking you kind of right about that
I really hope that someone makes a
creepypasta called big face and it's
just huge [ __ ] face but poor [ __ ]
christ got him
sorry I'm in frickin Christ go get the
meat oh I thought I was just a murderer
there's another one other Fox oh it's
it's it's husband wife oh I didn't get
the meat I just took the whole thing
dude there's a raccoon bang oh I missed
you're terrible I am quite bad oh well
it's called back girl David - what
yeah well it's day two men still might
remember the first day dude listen I
don't know if you've heard of midnight
but it crosses days in the middle of the
night man okay that doesn't count as day
two I mean technically if you're looking
at the Gregorian calendar my dude all
the way back to the Mayans yeah they
mark their days properly what are some
identifiers for when he shows up like
what we here at the big feet yeah you'll
hear a lot of loud thumping usually your
first indicator that he's showing up is
either him caving your face in or me
screaming so if you hear me screaming or
you see him approaching that's usually
an indicator that he is on the way can
he attack at any moment and yeah
literally any time Oh Malcolm why I'm so
skilled
God get that [ __ ] out here dude I've
changed over the years I can tell for
the worse yeah oh yeah now that now that
I hear it back I can see that I am the
[ __ ] big face in the face every time
I turn I think I'm hearing other
footsteps I know that's a problem with
this game but also creepy factor of this
game
hmm I'm gonna do shrooms and forget
about it all right man you do that I've
changed
oh [ __ ]
all right so wolves actually are a thing
this game it's cuz I would hear right I
would hear wolves all the time and be
like ah that's just ambience no and then
I got attacked by a wolf so wolves are
uh then I had no ankles yeah exactly
okay uh weird dear Jill tur to the shell
turning I don't see a goddamn thing hmm
I found a clue big face loves his his
standard drink just drink that's a good
slogan for alcohol commercials just
drink [ __ ] it it's Friday 5:00 p.m. your
life's going nowhere why not just drink
drink come on oh no I'm on sober per
that's long enough it's just medicine
yeah the alleys go away yeah it's self
medication come on this is horrible by
the way no one take this seriously
please for the love yes please Jesus
Christ all right time for a swim
we can swim in Minecraft what no this is
not minecraft man looks like minecraft I
want sniper rifles nothing alright well
I expected that to work it's really
weird that it didn't big face your pull
out game is weak he's in the middle of
bounine
he's in the middle of boring big-ass
[Laughter]
this is delightful so far spooky game
not so spooky no no not that spooky well
I mean until he shows up and then it
gets real okay oh [ __ ] you had to say it
this late
got big asked hired oh yeah that's
definite big ass yeah she's about to
become little skull real soon
let's just keep moving we are having
very bad luck with the number of bullets
yeah this doesn't seem to be going very
well yeah we technically have a knife
but it is not a good idea to go
mano-a-mano with Bigfoot this is Big
Brother big hands he'll show up go God
not just it's not that his hands are big
it's his fingers are just [ __ ]
massive creepy gives great hugs though
and great hand jobs best hand jobs can't
even describe okay all right okay all
right signal flare Oh he grabbed me with
the big hands you see that tiny ticket
off that gun me shooting him in his big
face yeah I missed a lot I did not do
good there it's okay we got next time I
can't don't lose her yeah he knows that
we're wimpy as [ __ ] and then we do like
we're no threat at all that was
horrifying yeah no he's not fun uh he's
real unfun he's the fun taker away
yeah but great hand jobs man you cannot
deny that was hand jobs are like
next-level yeah not like big face big
face it's got big face but a little
mouth yeah no not fun no [ __ ]
potential there's just nothing goes
great with the rapper lil dick though oh
yeah of course yeah absolutely
are people glad that we're back
recording together again
not like this not like this okay
okay hit him with a flare load up a
flare god I didn't know Angelo the Jesus
Clarke a was fine face it's fine I hit
him with some tracking Bullas I hit him
with dragon bullets we can now see him
good should we chase him no no God
please no why are you chasing I don't
know all right
this if we hit him with a dragon but we
know when he's gonna come for us again
and we can lay out a trap ah so what's
gonna happen is we lay out traps and
then we cover him with leaves and when
he charges you you walk him over the
trap and you'll get fries he just bailed
oh yeah yeah he he'll he's a runner he's
athletic he is just fit he is peak
performance yeah how many bullets you
got 10/21 all right yeah take no no go
for it you you go for it I'll focus on
like trying to track him okay okay we're
doing better on bullets than we were we
just gotta stop missing it me I I have
to stop miss you're doing fine I haven't
hit a single shot no I think you did
that damage just now okay good thank you
man I appreciate this you you be tick
thank you that's what they call me
that's what I want to be called big tick
big brain thank you that's me I have
those okay game plan when he shows up
should I be firing flares or should I
try and avoid and shoot should i from
now on we need to start trapping him
okay cause if we don't trap him we will
not do nearly enough damage cuz we got
to hit him with headshots to do bonus
damage I don't know Frank
no it's still there for me he's up in
the lake he's like sitting in the lake I
don't know what he's doing in the middle
of the lake she's just sitting there
twiddling his big big thumbs of his big
dick title of this video is big face big
dick big ass no problem it's gonna go up
to nobody no one's gonna see this video
T monetize immediately confirm by manual
review oh yeah we're we're killing it on
the bullet train this is good yeah now
all you have to do is kill it on the
killing it
we got a first-aid kit and that's it I
got it there's nothing else here get
outta here just drink just
I mean there's always the strangest
drink hey forget your troubles this
video sponsored by Jack Daniels just
drink okay this is not a good message
man but hey it's like our audiences are
growing up with us and as yeah as they
grow up and lose the innocence of
childhood I'd like to think they can
take a joke
and I don't have to spell out that
everything is sarcasm yeah that yeah
sarcasm that's what it is
hey where's big teeth got big teeth
the tracking did wear off this time so
let's see if we can make it to hunting
Tower and then when we get to hunting
tower we squat down yes you're up do you
want to play this like serious to try to
actually kill him yeah okay lights out
I'm a gamer what do you think I'm gonna
do lights out then did you grab a night
vision course is a nitrogen eye I told
you to be my teacher all right then grab
a night vision is because of your lack
of advanced lights out you fool right
have my lights on turn lights out light
out
turn it off oh oh lights off they said
lights out like take your light note
yeah what is what does lights-out mean
in Ireland okay we don't say like okay
kids time for bed lights out we just say
go to [ __ ] to sleep all right well
that's that's fair enough
turn your lights on or off just drink
drink kids shut up and drink yeah just
drink yeah here's your night whiskey is
my Irish impression it's gotten better
right here's your night whiskey it has
it was pretty damn atrocious before one
night-vision camera battery and that's
it really got him okay so what I'm gonna
do is I'm actually gonna meet up this
trap I'm gonna meet it up and then we're
gonna step back from it okay do I have
to like stare at it as I step back
there's a procedure I feel like if I
don't look at it it'll get closer do you
know how to sit down a trap I have no
idea how to do anything okay press Q
take I have a trap in my hand okay put
it on the ground
OOP now on it you can see like take
place meat and mask just ask it don't
place meat if he goes for that trap with
meat on it but he comes for us instead
he's gonna run straight over and we're
gonna make him run over it
okay I like it I know right big face big
ass big dick but we got big brain we got
big brain all day now just if he
actually comes here is the question yeah
how long does he stay trapped for like
maybe three seconds it's not god this
game this game is impossible it's real
tough man but you gotta believe you
gotta nail those headshots everything
will be good it'll be fine
I wouldn't like [ __ ] him I want to
like blow his kneecaps out Jesus Christ
man what I want to send a message what
what message that we don't [ __ ] around
I'm real mean I can see that man but you
don't need to be yeah it's true
you can be real nice it could be I'm
nice to people but not to big faces
alright fair but this isn't big face
this is big foot big hand big dick but
not big face big whatever anything big
you're going down well apparently not
cuz we're terrible killing him
we're not terrible at killing him we're
just getting started the the hammer has
not like laid down as they say in
America dead the gone it's not drunk no
no no it's a very no it's a very popular
American saying the hammer has not laid
down everyone says it we all know it
trust all has not yet fallen to the
ground yet exactly you know American
colloquialisms wow I I do I've had a lot
of practice very impressive I'm in
thoroughly impressed where the Frick is
Bigfoot he's just hiding behind it's
like hey guys we're looking at you guys
wait for the meet - me - yeah I don't
know what is oh [ __ ] he's coming no
that's a wolf nevermind that's a wolf
okay yeah I said that day three wait
give us give us a nice deep day three
even you have a good deep voice already
give us a big one
oh man it really hurts my throat to do
that
what speak all right I I'm go I'm gonna
go tinkle
you wait here all right if from God
saved my life
LT posed for to assert dominance cool
good good good plan okay
keep better not show up right this
second when we're doing this here why
did I agree to this big face big face
this is a big map and a big world we
live in
it's hard to find a soulmate but I can
be that for you I can be [ __ ] is
happening alright well just giving big
face some words of encouragement to find
a soulmate cuz it's a big bad world out
there alright okay man
you want to just move on then sure
alright cool grab your trap I'll grab
mine I don't know why I didn't show up
he usually does for me
but he's not hungry alright moving on
we're gonna go to an unknown cave okay
that sounds good if he shows up right
after we start moving up Oh God
oh my god are you serious are you [ __ ]
are you oh my god okay get my flare okay
did you get them yeah you got it
I swear to God hurts just wait 10 more
seconds what a sack of dick dick hole I
can't believe that's the second time
you've mentioned him and he's just shown
up in a mist for tonight what'd she just
say I miss fortnight yeah miss fortnight
man you just missed the idea for names
yeah love with the idea fortnight but I
don't want fortnight yeah exactly
oh [ __ ] he turned to her he's coming
wait did he turn around
no yes no I
tell who's come lay down a trap lay down
a trap trap trap trap trap I'm asking or
am I trying mask it just there we go
okay mask it if he comes I'm gonna try
to walk him right over here you come
from you [ __ ]
you come all right for me I see where
come on he's right in the mountain how's
he doing that don't step on the getup
it's very day I'll be bait Oh No I'm a
scared lonely little survivor my teeny
hands and my tiny bones
I hear he's coming okay get up get
behind your traps behead ye alright
where is he
where'd he go what the he's another
level he's like down below us yeah he I
think we might get some pot shots on him
where is he going he was just here
he's gone completely out you've got to
be kidding me I'm taking my trip this is
[ __ ] this guy is like I swear he
could hear our mics or something like
that alright there's a cave there's a
cave up here might have some goodies
okay yeah he's just out I think we I
think he was like down below we could
have just shot him from top but I didn't
know then we were cowards we were we his
behind our traps specifically you were a
coward Hey I okay I'm just gonna let
that one slide because I know you don't
mean it I know you're just lashing out
yeah probably letting his slug cuz
you're a coward okay I know you have
bullets and everything but your words
hurt most of all yeah whatever man I can
call myself a coward but you can't call
me a coward right right it's your p.m.
this forest it is nice you wanna go into
the swamp
sure cool man I love mucky boots oh yeah
this smells good yeah this is the good
stuff place thing what are we working
with another trap that's good a whole
single first aid kit great dude tactical
shovel you love those me I love that's
my thing alright whatever watching high
screw like what did you practical show
for the digging part I'm like I film
this so long ago playing this way before
you don't know how time works
ah we should do battle in an open field
it's big that's not the kind of thing or
person that you do battle with did say
we could peer pressure into doing
shrooms or something
Oh mrs. Pierce I don't know how big of
your feet not big enough if we stack on
top of each other and put a trench coat
over us do you think he'll give us that
work yeah either it attract him or
really attract him
there's something about French good this
is my Bigfoot impressive ooh me me like
a trench coat something kind of focused
me big like oh oh he's here he's here
okay I'm laying out trap laying out trap
he's walking he said the right of us
okay I'm laying out trap masking it okay
I'm ready this time he ain't gonna get
towards the swamp good where is he I'm
gonna I'm gonna lead him to us where is
he
who's there all right okay yeah come on
where you going buddy did you get him
did I hit him I don't know it's the tree
got in my way God it what is with this
guy I can't see the Bigfoots through
through the trees you know that good old
thing that's the thing yeah that's the
same wait wait I don't know he's being
really bizarre
I'm gonna take my trap and go going to
hunting Tower too stupid too cool you're
not cool yeah you think you got big feet
you got big aspirations what is that did
did you hear that I thought I heard of
no I heard me making a shitty joke okay
well I I will laugh at that I promise I
will do another trap yes you know it's
it's a bad joke dude I probably I'm so
supportive of you and your jokes thank
you good and bad well I don't know if
you should do that that'll put me down a
bad rabbit hole no no come on man
your if you tell me everything's funny
then nothing's funny and everything you
do everything you want to say the things
say your thing say your thing okay you
guys ready yeah yeah oh God
just drink what I'm trying to cut down
attacking this tent there's stuff in the
tenon I can't get to it
open the tent go in try it oh yeah he's
so smart you just go in the tent
oh god how'd you get in the tent we look
like an idiot don't do this to me
you just get into ten you have to keep
knifing it oh I can see it's through the
tenth look hi
go away big face
go away tenth face there's only one
other place that we can go to get items
now supposedly Nebraska monsters lair
why would we
that's something cool [ __ ] here's good
how many cup where do they come from
oh dude I don't know how to break this
to you yeah but your ass is split in
half Oh God Jesus can give me some of
your ass dude I only have one I can't be
throwing it around come on come on you
know you want to please sir may I have
more ass
that's the Oliver Twist prostitute
edition exactly please pimp can I have
more ass funny jokes jokes cross that
off the list joke okay done all right
great great great okay next on the list
is pander to audience how do we do that
alright hey guys I love you know do it
do the thing you do do the thing you do
in the video no you're not dying not
this time no good heel you're fine Oh
game is BS he knew we're at his monster
lair and he tried to mess with us he did
I didn't even get a tracking bullet off
on a man that's okay my my dude
my main man I don't think we're gonna
kill this okay I wanna shoot you if you
keep up with that adage all right yeah
I'm sorry you know about PMA positive
mental I do
you gotta you gotta do it okay been such
a bad boy I'm gonna be good dude it's
okay just go to my store by the mercury
oh yeah I've been so bad yeah what are
you doing I have a very positive mental
attitude smack you with my floppy banana
I don't want that it sounds worse than
it is it's just a floppy banana I know
you thinking it I've seen it I've seen
it
let's go you you you've seen my fluffy
banana Wow how did you get for being a
lizard person God yeah I got you I got
you
that do that to big face a thousand
times
alright here's here's what we're gonna
do all right we're gonna yes another
markiplier planet site listen shut up
I'll first up shut up don't you
we're going to lay out meat traps tons
of them Hey lay the trap hopefully the
Wolves don't come I hope they come I in
fact I welcome it okay big face no we
should do we should surround ourselves
in traps we should I'm trying to figure
out why the traps you don't know where
the traps are I'm scared I'm believing
it's fine walking directly into them all
right big face I'm all scared and alone
out here in the woods whatever am I
gonna do with all this meat
oh no that's big face I'm dummy thick oh
so huge so hard for you big feet
oh oh oops he's not here okay
I'm prostituting myself for no reason I
usually do that for views it's not
working you know what that means
everybody's gotta like this video these
videos and send them to all your friends
and watch them a million times they do
that is a fact that is just what they
have to do now a billion times
screw a million I've seen a million a
billion would be preferable to be
perfectly honest do you think we'd ever
get a billion viewed video uh us
probably not that's reserves from
music videos I didn't I literally don't
think there's any other type of video
that could get a billion views besides a
music video okay we need to make a
Bigfoot song you first Bigfoot is my
friend oh yeah he is not my enemy so he
should come and find us find us cuz we
have good meat meat so tender Dave for
do my improv off the charity know your
pops great my monetization is just
tanked every word okay
censor out asks and replace it with
Jesus yeah if also lick seeing could you
do that as well I want to put my
friendship in your Jesus that's it
that's the one do me think Jesus I want
to put my Jesus inside your [ __ ]
no no no no listen you messed up there
think about it again okay rillette it
alright Jesus my Jesus inside your [ __ ]
Jesus [ __ ] Jesus let's see Jesus we got
something what do we got wait what wait
what what Ella Fox of course you me to
destroy the meat well this is working
out this is going terribly
let's move out it's my fault I feel I
should no no no just because dialer was
better at this than you are see why
you've increased my insecurity no no no
dialers was stunning at this we almost
killed him together through the power of
our friendship we almost go okay what
did he make up good songs like improv we
he was funny he was like non-stop
hilarious I just feel anxious an
insecure and paranoid about the
performance that I'm giving in this
content well I mean you don't have to be
insecure about her anxious because you
know that he was better like that's just
a fact
so you can accept that you see okay no
we've done we
and it's not for lack of trying
we're really free skeezits act us a
bunch she just does it for so many he is
not going for this bait ma'am uh should
I miss Jesus Christ as a fox I it was
loud in the game and then you were loud
in discord and everything was loud
look man welcome to us recording it's
loud that's true Wow it's very loud very
loud remember what we used to scream all
the time yeah I said well I still do but
why oh yeah me too
good God doesn't see him this is so I
think what happens is like usually he
gets more aggressive as time goes on
because he's taking a lot more damage
this in this particular year we have
done nothing to him
oh [ __ ] god you're got him you look a
good shot
that was that was hip fire too you
should play fortnight or something I
want to play the new zombie mode and pub
G I hear they updated it's been so long
since we played zombies I want to
actually do it again yeah we did the
four of us that was super fun yeah yeah
we should get the guys together again
we should rustle up the gang let's
rustle up the gang get the mystery van
out and just go [ __ ] some ghosts oh
that's what the do and scooby-doo means
I don't know about that scooby-doo is
just the name of the dog no Scooby do
you is his full name or excuse me
scooby-doo is just a stage name Oh God
who would name a dog scooby-doo you he
wasn't he wasn't always a dog what you
don't know about the deep lore of
scooby-doo
no man I don't scooby-doo is the
original creepypasta why why what the
hell I don't make it up I just consume
so Scooby was like cursed a long time
ago and that's why they're always out
trying to solve mysteries because
they're trying to get to the bottom of
this weird curse have you you're like oh
he's just a regular dog named scooby-doo
have you ever wondered why he's able to
talk you know I guess I've never really
considered it it is a little weird when
you think about it I'm waiting for that
final episode of scooby-doo where they
finally pull the mask off Scooby himself
and it was like Shaggy's dad all along
that's that's messed up on like a lot of
levels dude I don't know if you know
this I'm a very good storyteller
I can I'm enraptured thank you thank you
I'm also trying to fill time because
nothing is happening he usually is more
active we are uselessly capable of doing
a bit more damage and usually if he's if
he's gunning for us we can usually see
him from far enough away that we can set
out a trap and trick him he's just kind
of creeping up on us yeah I don't know
how he's doing that like that wolf just
came out of nowhere yeah I did not hear
that wolf all right how about this we go
out in the middle of the swamp he does
go to the swamp he has frequently go to
the swamp so if we hang out here we
should see him we should be able to lay
a trap out and you should see him coming
from distance as well welcome up [ __ ]
wolves I am ready to [ __ ] Bigfoot oh
really
can you replace that [ __ ] with like a
Minecraft eating sound minecraft
minecraft good so good for monetization
so you put enough sound spin
I don't think it's any better in visla
I'm ready to Bigfoot I'm just gonna
really get in between those cheeks in
Minecraft start an impression thank you
that's what I'm here for
I'm just gonna start laying meat on the
ground just in the hopes that he stops
by because this is ridiculous we haven't
seen him in like 30 minutes I know right
what if the game actually has like sound
sensing like it picks up your mic
Bigfoot Bigfoot you mentioned it before
and you show it off mention him again
hey you know I miss Bigfoot I miss his
face I miss his smell that's impossible
all right now I'm gonna flirt I'm gonna
flare up I'm gonna flare him I'm gonna
flare hmm oh we both flare them alright
no I okay I'm gonna try track him here
we go got him did I get him I saw got it
okay I tracked him holy [ __ ] that's
that's absurd that is wild that's banana
sandwich
my head I was like what if he actually
does show I think there's no [ __ ] way
Oh city's coming back what he's coming
back Jesus Holy Mother of I'm dying
you're not dying I'm laying on the
ground
it says I'm dying listen man can I can I
met kit my soul no I'll get you listen
you should keep shooting them
I got him listen here there you go now
that was my last med kit so I am dying I
have two left all right
Oh is he coming back out of my mouth
traps man I got traps
I got traps your dailies coming can you
see him yeah I see he's breeze up on the
ridge he's 30 to 40 percent of him done
now that's good
I am almost out of bullets okay can I
drop bullets for you I also have traffic
out in the woods so if he it says he'll
take some damage I wish we could find
like a pipe bomb and put that in the
meat that and put that in the trap be
great I cannot believe he showed up when
you mentioned look man I've got a very
specific superpower it's not useful for
anything and it really meant find out
your super is that you played Bigfoot on
Steam he's really coming for my house
right now he's like booking it down the
way so yeah a few hours here I've really
boned but hey it'll make for great
content and that's what it's all about
right that is what it's all about that's
all it's ever been about that's all it's
ever been about this what I'm saying
good content good like button comment
subscribe merch
yeah
yeah heist with markiplier ice with
markiplier yeah chase what ending did
you get YouTube promotion Amos and
Jackson hashtag a hwm complier you said
their names
oh god my cameras already glitching out
oh god not your camera - turns out my
camera's just dying
Oh your guy has the thing on his hat I
thought you had your ears pierced dude
man oh god don't like it hey gonna catch
me a light lizard person now uh there's
a thumbnail it turn off your light and
let me go thumbnail here you're a lady
yeah wait is this better yeah I don't
know where we went wrong but we went
really wrong cuz we were like Tyler and
I we were down to like a sliver of
Health left and we ran out of bullets I
thought that we were gonna like
carefully plan this one execute the plan
very cautiously then oh yeah that was a
mistake on your part you know me man
I don't do that yeah you know kind of in
the group right right right that's my
role uh-huh yeah well yeah I make
funnies and I don't play well I think
the truth is that we all need to learn
is that we are all the dumb one and none
of us are the smart one anyway Bigfoot
you know right big sweet I love them I
love big item Bigfoot he's spitting
straight feet I thought this would have
works it worked every other time me
mentioned in Bigfoot but I guess not
this time right that's what you were
doing
I've surrounded myself with me I've got
my night-vision camera out I want the
sweetest thumbnail that ever existed it
becomes charging about my ass with this
nitrogen out we just need this sweet
conclusion we have to go out [ __ ]
balls to the wall baby
Dom's yeah yeah man my ball is always on
every wall I touch all walls with my
balls like a weird sports tradition if
did I touch each part of the doorframe
just to make sure your team wins
it's gonna slap my sack every walk it's
like Cougars are playing today
dude it's tradition slap your balls like
it hurts but the win is so worth it I
can feel it go Cougs yeah okay I'm just
gonna head into the forest on my own all
right have fun I'll be here surrounded
by me
you know how in the horror movies
they're always like let's split up and
it goes really well yeah yeah we're
sticking together you're right yes I
think you're right about that I think
you're absolutely right
the slowest game of Bigfoot and I cannot
believe this this is absurd oh god do I
dare try and get down the mountain on my
own well I am dying dying got me
forgot you oh no this is that The Legend
of toss boy ends I'm gonna go inland and
I don't know man
huh I heard him are you yeah he's right
on my body what is it by you I don't
know he just went running by he's
heading towards monster lair I think
okay all right turned up in that
direction I'm headed up there to get
[ __ ] him up I'm all [ __ ] for you I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do him [ __ ]
Bigfoot I will oh yeah yeah I'll be
thinking of you thinking of my big face
oh there he is
oh hey Bigfoot um dude all right I'm
waiting for it to go down hey I see he's
not coming to me oh [ __ ] he's coming to
me Oh God oh my god hey I didn't see the
health go down and now I'm watching a
cut see I'm only assuming that you want
[Laughter]
my screen shot he just he was so close
by the time like how much big Bigfoot
damage did you do to 14 I only did one
10 the whole goal was to [ __ ] Bigfoot
but it turns our Bigfoot [ __ ] us
[Music]